the more technology advances the larger
our file sizes get and the smaller our
hard drives are getting so today we're
looking at online cloud storage what's
going on guys my name is David homage
and welcome back to the channel today
we're gonna be comparing Google Drive
onedrive and Dropbox
these three have been the kings of cloud
storage for a little while now and they
are definitely the mainstream cloud
storage solutions but what makes him
different what makes them great and
which one should you choose for your
personal reasons and why today we're
gonna compare them in depth see what
they do see what features they have seen
how much they cost and decide which one
is the best for you so if we look at
this from a three column grid it's
Google Drive onedrive and Dropbox
each of these devices gives you a free
amount of data that you can basically
test out the software and see if you
like it or not
Dropbox comes in with the least amount
of data it gives you two gigabytes for
free whereas Google Drive gives you 15
gigabytes for free whilst onedrive comes
in the middle with five gigabytes based
on storage alone and if that's the only
thing you're looking for Google Drive is
definitely the clear winner here because
it provides you with 15 gigabytes of
free storage under one email account you
don't have to go and create a million
different email accounts to try get some
more storage out of it like you would in
Dropbox if you're anything like me you
spend a lot of time at the computer and
you wrap up your file size pretty
quickly so to do bytes is definitely not
enough for free and 15 gigabytes only
lasts a few weeks if you're looking to
upgrade to the next category it might
cost you a little bit but not as much as
you might think the one reason I suggest
cloud storage to a lot of people with
small laptops is for the simple fact
that it removes a lot of data from your
computer frees up space and makes it run
faster so if you have a macbook air for
example with a hundred and twenty six
gigabytes of storage or 120
bytes of storage I think it is that's
not a lot of storage to install apps
programs and have your personal data
especially if you'd like to take a lot
of photos moving up to a hundred
gigabytes of data is relatively cheap
and affordable for most people around
the world now for some people that could
be a very false statement but I'm hoping
it this series here isn't too
unaffordable for most people so if we
look at it and break it down for a
hundred gigabytes of storage per month
Google Drive charges you $2.49
Australian whilst onedrive charges you
three dollars flat Australian Dropbox
unfortunately doesn't offer anything in
between two gigabytes and the next jump
is two terabytes so we'll get there a
little bit later on Google drive's
advantage again over onedrive and
Dropbox is the fact that it has an
incremental leap at 200 gigabytes for
four dollars and 29 cents per month I
don't know what it is with Google and
these odd numbers but it seems to work
for them onedrive steps it up to one
terabyte at $10 a month which is
definitely a leap up and becomes
unaffordable for some people the great
thing about onedrive though at this $10
a month bundle is the fact that you get
Word Excel PowerPoint and basically the
office 365 suite included in this
monthly package so programs that you're
more than likely going to use all the
time or already use all the time are
included in this bundle yes Google Drive
does give you Google Docs and Google
sheets and all of the Google comparisons
for absolutely free in this and it does
suck you in with that for sure
Dropbox on the other hand has introduced
a new paper feature which again gives
you the sort of collaboration
practicality type templates that you can
use for word style documents Excel style
documents and just to collaborate with
your team so each one of them does have
their own unique office administrative
tools if you're looking at using
something for your business or your
personal life so going back to Google
Drive and back to Dropbox you can get
two terabytes respectively at $12.49 and
18 dollars and 69 cents
a month now let's get into what really
separates these platforms what makes
them different and unique and it doesn't
make them just a cloud storing solution
so all three of these platforms share
some unique features for example they
give you desktop folders directly
inbuilt into your browser Chrome which
means you don't have to open up Google
Chrome or Safari every time go to
onedrive Google Drive downloaded files
upload them that's just a huge pain all
three of them allow you to install an
app into your computer which then allows
you to access your files directly off
the computer itself as if it was stored
on your computer where it gets
interesting for me is the fact of how
these programs allocate and install
their software into your computer Google
Drive for example saves everything to
your hard drive which is fantastic
because it's a local backup of your
cloud storage solution onedrive doesn't
onedrive saves everything to the cloud
and downloads it as it needs to unless
you choose otherwise and Dropbox does
the same as Google Drive now this is a
personal choice and a personal
preference I do like having everything
saved to my hard drive because the local
backup but at the same time I do like
the fact onedrive has the feature of
pushing everything to the cloud and only
grabbing it when you need to this means
you save a lot of space on your hard
drive especially if you don't have any
space at all all of these cloud sharing
platforms allow you to share these
folders with absolutely anybody via a
link or an email address so if you want
to collaborate with another person get
them to share files with you that are
too big for email this is the best way
to get them to drop these files into
these folders you can save absolutely
any file it doesn't matter what it is
you can't open every single file without
a program and built into it but you can
save them into that storage solution all
of them provide offline features which
is where you can download it to computer
use it absolutely anytime or download it
to your mobile device via the app and
store it again on your device and look
at it anytime they all have amazing
search features inside them which allow
you to quickly search for the file and
find it very
quickly if you're a Windows user you're
definitely used to a slow search history
whereas Mac's
are much much quicker with this so if
you're a Mac user you're used to being
able to search for file finding it
instantaneously that's what you're gonna
get on these cloud storage solutions and
one of my favorite features on all three
of these is the fact that it saves
versions of your files so if you
overwrite a file for example and usually
on a Windows or a Mac computer you'd
save it
you'd overwrite it and you'd go oh no I
can't get this file back it's gone for a
lot more you have to do a software
recovery or file recovery and it's a
nightmare with a cloud storage solution
you can easily go to that cloud storage
solution and find the old file from up
to 30 days ago and bring it back so if
you've overwritten a file accidentally
named it the wrong thing and overwritten
something you can easily undo your
mistakes from an encryption point of
view and a data security point of view
all three obviously encrypted with your
password so nobody can access it until
they know your password or unless they
hack your password onedrive takes this a
step further and provides you with a
personal vault they call it inside
onedrive so you can actually store
additional files that you consider
extremely private so for example a
passport or a driver's license inside
the personal vault and if you're using
it on a mobile device it can only be
accessed via biometrics so your
thumbprint your face etc this file is
definitely something to consider if you
have a lot of personal files because
neither Google Drive or Dropbox allow
added layers of security like onedrive
does if they're PDFs or Word documents
you can obviously password protect them
over and above your original password I
always suggest having multiple passwords
different passwords for everything from
a cyber security point of view what you
do absolutely your choice now if you're
a business user or a business
professional with that has a website and
then at your website condone a you.com
whatever it is email address you
probably have access to either Google or
Outlook through this provider if you do
have a business profile for example
Google gives you up to 30 gigabytes for
free whereas
the one drive if you purchased it
through the right channels and through
the right domain names gives you one
terabyte and an access to all their
office 365 products so again from a
business point of view really really
good to have either Google Drive or
onedrive now this is where it really
really sets it apart for me especially
Google Drive like I mentioned before has
Google sheets in Google Docs onedrive
has Word Excel PowerPoint etc now for me
I use a lot of Word documents a lot of
Excel documents when I'm not using 3d
rendering programs or architectural
design programs these things usually
can't be run on my mobile device on an
iPad or any small portable personal
device they have to be running off a
powerful laptop and a powerful computer
so it doesn't bother me that I can't
open them up on a cloud storage solution
what does bother me is the fact that
with Google Drive for example I can't
directly open up my Excel document edit
it save it be done I have to download it
change it reload it or I have to create
a Google sheets for example whereas with
onedrive it's a very simple procedure
now this is coming from me personally
because I've obviously grown up using
365 platform I've grown up using Word
and Excel so I use them all the time the
last 20 ideas of data for me are in Word
Excel PowerPoint etc so it's very easy
for me to go onedrive is the best
platform if you're using office 365
products and personally it is just that
simple if you're not using office 365
products all three are fantastic the
best one for price affordability of
features and everything in between is
definitely Google Drive so if you aren't
using 365 products and you're happy to
use Google sheets and Google Docs
instead of Word and Excel then Google is
definitely one of the better cloud
storage solutions here for usually half
the price anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
smash that subscribe button
20:20 style and being Friday today
more quarantine content coming very soon
so I'll see you on Monday